ASSEMBLY MEMBER WAKES NOTICES
THE ABSENCE OF A QUORUM.
THE SERGEANTS AT ARMS WILL
PREPARE THE CHAMBER AND BRING IN
THE ABSENT MEMBERS AND THE CLERK
WILL CALL THE ROLL.
AGUIAR-CURRY ARAMBULA.
OUR QUE HAN.
BERMAN.
BIGELOW.
BLOOM.
BURNER* BATH.
BONTA [inaudible]
BRO [inaudible]
BURKE.
CALDERON CARILLO CERVANTES CHAU
CHEN.
DAVID CHIU.
CHOI KANSEN CHU COOLEY COOPER.
CUNNINGHAM DALLY DALY DEEP.
EIGHT MEN FLORA FONG.
FRAZIER FRIEDMAN GABRIEL.
GALLAGHER CRISTINA GARCIA
EDUARDO GARCIA [inaudible]
GIPSON GLORIA GONZALEZ AS GRAY.
GRAYSON HOLDEN.
IRWIN JONES SAWYER.
KALRA KAMLAGER-DOVE OF KILEY.
LACKEY LEVINE LIMON ON LOW.
MAIENSCHEIN MATHIS MAYES MCCARTY
MEDINA.
MELENDEZ MULLIN MURATSUCHI
NAZARIAN OBERNOLTE O'DONNELL
PATTERSON PEACHTREE NORRIS QUIRK
[inaudible]
QUIRK SILVA.
ROM OF RAY IS --
THREE OF US ROBERT REAVIS
RODRIGUEZ RUBIO [inaudible]
SALAS SANTIAGO SMITH
[inaudible]
STONE.
TEEN VOEPEL [inaudible]
WALDRON WEBER WAKES WOOD MISTER
SPEAKER
.
MEMBERS IN A QUORUM IS PRESENT.
A QUORUM IS PRESENT IN THE
ASSEMBLY.
WE ASK OUR GUESTS AND VISITORS
IN THE REAR OF THE CHAMBER AND
IN THE GALLERY TO PLEASE STAND
FOR THE PRAYER.
TODAY'S PRAYER WILL BE OFFERED
BY OUR ASSEMBLY CHAPLAIN THE
REVEREND PATTY OSHA RECORD OF
PLEASE JOIN ME IN A MOMENT OF
REFLECTION.
IT WAS REPORTED THAT THE
DRENCHING RAIN IN THE STRONG
WINDS OF THE RECENT STORMS.
HAD UPROOTED OVER ONE HUNDRED
TREES IN SACRAMENTO.
WHEN THE FALLEN OAK TREE SHOWN
IN THE NEWS SEEM TO HAVE BEEN
OVER FIVE FEET IN DIAMETER?
AND CURLY WAIT THOUSANDS OF
POUNDS.
FROM ANCIENT TIMES.
ARE HUMAN CULTURES HAVE
PERSONIFIED MANY TREES WITH
VIRTUES TO BE ADMIRED AND EVEN
EMULATED.
THE MIGHTY OAK WAS OFTEN SEEN AS
REGAL AND STRONG. FOR CENTURIES
IN JAPAN. THREE TREES WERE
ASSOCIATED WITH THE WINTER
SEASON.
THE PINE THE BAMBOO AND THE PLUM.
THERE'S EVEN A SPECIAL FLOWER
ARRANGEMENT MADE FOR THE NEW
YEAR CALL SHOW TOO GOODBYE.
MEANING PINE BAMBOO AND PLAN.
AND IT IS CREATED WITH THOSE
THREE ELEMENTS.
THE PINE IS EVERGREEN IN
SYMBOLIZES THE VIRTUES.
OF ENDURANCE DURING THE MOST
ADVERSE CIRCUMSTANCES.
THE BAMBOO EMBODIES THE VIRTUE
RESILIENCE FOR EVEN DURING THE
MOST TORRENTIAL STORMS.
IT WOULD BEEN BEEN NEVER BREAK
SOME TREE WAS A MARTYR FOR IT
WOULD BE THE FIRST TO BLOOM WITH
LIFE.
EVEN AS THE WINTER SNOW REMAINED.
THE PALM TREES DELICATE BLOSSOMS
RADIATED HOPE IN BEAUTY.
DEEP WITHIN.
WE STILL ADMIRE THE VIRTUES THAT
OUR ANCESTORS SAW IN THE WONDER
OF NATURE ALL AROUND US.
WHEN TIMES SEEM HARDER'S?
THE IMAGE OF THE PINE BAMBOO IN
PLUM.
REMINDERS TO INJURE DEPRESSIVE
YEAR WITH GENTLE RESILIENCE.
AND NEVER GIVE IN TO DESPAIR.
FOR WHAT IS HOPEFUL IN BEAUTIFUL
WITHIN THE HUMAN SPIRIT.
WILL PREVAIL.
NUMBER ONE WE DON'T SUIT.
SEC NOTICE LIVE WHAT KINDNESS
AND GRATITUDE BEYOND WORDS.
THANK YOU REVEREND WE ASK OUR
GUESTS AND VISITORS TO REMAIN
STANDING.
AND JOIN US FOR THE FLAG SALUTE
PLEASE JOIN ASSEMBLY MEMBER
GRAYSON AS HE LEADS US IN THE
PLEDGE MISTER GRACE.
I PLEDGE ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG.
STATES OF AMERICA [inaudible] TO
WHICH IS STANDS ONE NATION THERE
ARE [inaudible]
THIS WILL [inaudible]
CHESS.
THANK YOU YOU MAY BE SEATED.
READING OF THE PREVIOUS DAY'S
JOURNAL.
ASSEMBLY CHAMBER SACRAMENTO
MONDAY DECEMBER THIRD 2018% TO
THE PROVISIONS OF THE
CONSTITUTION OF THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA AT THE HOUR OF TWELVE
O'CLOCK MERIDIAN.
THE TWENTY NINETEEN TWENTY
REGULAR SESSION OF THE
LEGISLATURE WAS CALLED TO ORDER
BY E. DOTSON WILSON CHEAPER THE
ASSEMBLY FOR THE TWENTY
SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN REGULAR
SESSION.
IN CONFORMITY WITH THE LAW THE
BALLING OSTER CALDERON MOVES.
AND MISS WALDRON SECONDS.
THE READING OF THE PREVIOUS
DAY'S JOURNAL BE DISPENSED WITH.
PRESENTATIONS OF PETITIONS AN
INTRODUCTION A REFERENCE OF
BILLS WILL BE DEFERRED.
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
DEEMED ADOPTED.
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR THERE
ARE NONE.
MESSAGES FROM THE SENATE.
THERE ARE NONE.
MOVING TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS.
THE ABSENCES FOR THE DAY FOR
LEGISLATIVE BUSINESS.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER MONIQUE LIMON IN
ASSEMBLY MEMBER JAMES GALLAGHER.
FOR ILLNESS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CUNNINGHAM.
MISTER CALDERON YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR PROCEDURAL
MOTION THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
I REQUEST UNANIMOUS CONSENT TO
SUSPEND ASSEMBLY RULE FORTY FIVE
POINT FIVE TO ALLOW.
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS BLOOM GABRIEL
GRAY FLORA IRWIN AND RAMEAU'S TO
SPEAK ON IN IN GERMAN AND MEMORY
TODAY.
WITHOUT OBJECTION SUCH SHALL BE
THE ORDER [inaudible]
ANNOUNCEMENTS MEMBERS.
THE SESSION SCHEDULE IS AS
FOLLOWS FRIDAY JANUARY ELEVENTH
NO FLOOR SESSION NO CHECK IN
SESSION.
MONDAY JANUARY FOURTEENTH FLOOR
SESSION IS AT ONE PM.
MEMBERS WE ARE GOING TO MOVE TO
ADJOURNMENTS IN MEMORY AS SUCH I
WOULD ASK THAT YOU.
TAKE YOUR SEATS OR TAKE YOUR
CONVERSATIONS OFF OF THE FLOOR.
SO YOU MAY GIVE YOU RESPECTFUL
ATTENTION TO YOUR COLLEAGUES
WILL BE A TURNING IN THE MEMORY.
PLEASE TAKE YOUR SEATS MEMBERS.
WE ARE AT THE GERMANS
[inaudible]
IN MEMORY
.
MEMBERS WE ARE AT ADJOURNMENTS
[inaudible]
YEAH.
MEMBERS PLEASE GIVE YOUR
ATTENTION TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER --
WHEN?
WILL BE TURNING IN THE MEMORY
[inaudible]
ASSEMBLY MEMBER --
WENT.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER I RISE
TO ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY OF MY
FRIEND LEO VALENZUELA.
WHO PASSED AWAY ON NOVEMBER
TWENTY NINTH?
TWENTY EIGHTEEN IN OXNARD
CALIFORNIA.
A DISTINGUISHED MILITARY VETERAN
AND HIGHLY RESPECTED LABOR
LEADER.
HIS TIRELESS SERVICE EARNED HIM
THE ADMIRATION OF COUNTLESS
INDIVIDUALS IN HIS COMMUNITY.
AND ACROSS THE STATE.
UPON BEING DRAFTED INTO THE US
ARMY IN SEPTEMBER OF NINETEEN
SIXTY FIVE VALENZUELA SERVED IN
THE TWENTY FIFTH INFANTRY
DIVISION WHERE HE RECEIVED A
BRONZE STAR. FOR HIS SERVICE IN
VIETNAM.
HE CONTINUED TO SERVE HIS FELLOW
VETERANS AFTER RETURNING HOME BY
BUILDING WAR MEMORIALS AND
VENTURA COUNTY.
AN ORGANIZING SERVICES AND FOOD
DRIVES FOR HOMELESS VETERANS.
AFTER COMPLETING HIS SERVICE
VALENZUELA ENJOYED A FORTY SIX
YEAR LONG CAREER WITH THE
LABORERS UNION WHERE HE SERVED
IN VARIOUS LEADERSHIP POSITIONS.
AS THE BUSINESS MANAGER FOR
LOCAL FIVE EIGHT FIVE AND VICE
PRESIDENT FOR THE FIFTH DISTRICT
OF THE CALIFORNIA LABOR
FEDERATION.
LEO WAS A TIRELESS ADVOCATE IN
PROTECTING AND ADVANCING THE
RIGHTS OF WORKING PEOPLE IN
SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
AS A PROUD MEMBER OF THE SAN
FERNANDO BAND OF MISSION INDIANS.
FELONS WILLIS CELEBRATED HIS
NATIVE AMERICAN HERITAGE HE
WORKED DILIGENTLY TO FORM THE
OAK BROOK PARK CHUMASH INDIAN
CORPORATION.
AND AGO SHE HATED FOUR HUNDRED
AND TWENTY SEVEN ACRES OF PARK
LAND IN THOUSAND OAKS TO BUILD
THE CHUMASH CULTURAL AN
INTERPRETIVE CENTER.
I ASK YOU TO JOIN THE FRIENDS
AND FAMILY OF LEO VALENZUELA AND
CELEBRATING THE ACCOMPLISHMENTS
AND LEGACY.
OF A DISTINGUISHED AND CARING
INDIVIDUAL.
WHOSE GENEROUS SPIRIT WILL LIVE
ON IN THE HEARTS AND MEMORIES OF
ALL THOSE WHO HAD THE PLEASURE
OF KNOWING HIM.
THANK YOU ASSEMBLY MEMBER WHEN.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM FOR YOUR A
GERMAN IN MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS
SO I RISE TO ADJOURN IN THE
MEMORY OF AND ACTIVISTS LEADER.
AND TO SOMEONE THAT --
ROBIN I WERE VERY PROUD TO CALL
OUR FRIEND.
BARBARA AT AUSTIN HERE SLOT SKI
THE THE TRUTH OF THE MATTER IS
THAT AS SPECIAL RELATIONSHIP.
ROBBIE AND I FELT THAT WE HAD
WITH BARBARA.
ON SHE WAS A FRIEND TO EVERYONE
SHE MET AND NEARLY EVERYONE WHO
KNEW HER FELT THAT THEY HAD THAT
SAME VERY SPECIAL BOND WITH HER
THIS WAS.
DEMONSTRATED BY THE OUTPOURING
OF LOVE AND SENTIMENT FROM MANY
HUNDREDS OF PEOPLE WHO ATTENDED
HER MEMORIAL AND BURIAL JUST A
COUPLE OF WEEKS AGO.
BARBARA WAS ABLE TO CONNECT WITH
PEOPLE IN A PERSONAL WAY TO
SHARE HER INSIGHTS HER
INTELLIGENCE HER KIND HEART AND
HER PASSION FOR JUSTICE AND
HUMANITY.
SHE WAS A LIFELONG ANGELINO WHO
DIVIDED DEVOTED HER LIFE TO
SERVING HER CITY HER COMMUNITY.
AND REALLY.
ARE JUST PEOPLE EVERYONE WHO
NEEDED HELP BARBARA WAS THERE
FOR HER FOR THEM.
OVER THE COURSE OF HER LIFE
BARBER WAS AN ACTIVE VOLUNTEER
IN MEMBER OF MANY MANY NONPROFIT
AGENCIES.
STATEWIDE BOARDS --
INCLUDING THE CALIFORNIA MEDICAL
BOARD WHERE SHE WAS THE FIRST
NON PHYSICIAN TO SERVE ITS
PRESIDENT.
A SHE WAS ALSO A MEMBER OF HAD
BEEN A MEMBER OF THE CALIFORNIA
BOARD OF REGISTERED NURSING AND
THE LOS ANGELES COMMISSION ON
COMMUNITY.
AND FAMILY SERVICES BARBER WAS
STEAMED IN LOS ANGELES IS JEWISH
COMMUNITY SHE SERVED ON SEVERAL
BOARDS AT THE JEWISH FEDERATION
OF GREATER LOS ANGELES.
INCLUDING THE BOARD OF JEWISH
EDUCATION AND THE JEWISH PUBLIC
AFFAIRS COMMITTEE.
SHE PASSED AWAY ON DECEMBER --
TWENTY SIX TWENTY EIGHTEEN AFTER
BATTLING A RARE WEST NILE VIRUS
INFECTION.
AS MANY OF YOU KNEW.
SHE WAS THE WIFE OF FORMER LOS
ANGELES COUNTY SUPERVISOR AND
CITY COUNCIL MEMBER HAVE YEAR A
SLOB SKI.
THEY HAD MAD AT THE LOS ANGELES
HEBRON HIGH SCHOOL WHERE HE HAD
BEEN A HALL MONITOR IT'S KIND OF
HARD TO IMAGINES OF IS A HALL
MONITOR --
OR MAYBE NOT SO HARD --
BUT SHE WAS WORKING AT THE FRONT
DESK AT THAT TIME OF THE
AMERICAN JEWISH UNIVERSITY JUST
THE VERY BEGINNING OF A LIFETIME
OF SERVICE FOR BOTH OF THEM --
AND I THINK THAT WAS ONE OF THE
THE BONDS THAT THEY SHARED TO A
BEFORE AND AFTER THEY WERE
MARRIED IN.
NINETEEN SEVENTY ONE OVER THE
COURSE OF HER LIFE.
BARBARA EXEMPLIFIED THE VALUES
OF COMMUNITY SERVICE AND
ENGAGEMENT THAT WE ALL STRIVE.
FOR AND THREW HER SERVICE SHE
IMPROVE THE LIVES OF COUNTLESS
PEOPLE NOT ONLY THOSE IN LOS
ANGELES BUT ACROSS THE STATE AND
BEYOND.
SHE IS SURVIVED BY HER HUSBAND'S
THAT HAVE SON DAVID DAUGHTER
NINA FOUR GRANDCHILDREN HER
BROTHER AND SISTER AND OTHER
FAMILY MEMBERS AND OF COURSE.
COUNTLESS FRIENDS WHO WILL NEVER
FORGET HER NAY ASKED THAT WE
ADJOURN IN HER MEMORY.
NAME AS WELL SEVEN MEMBER
GABRIEL YOU ARE RECOGNIZED.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER
COLLEAGUES I ALSO RISE TODAY TO
ASK THAT WE JOURNEY IN MEMORY OF
BARBIE ARTS LOSSKY OF LOS
ANGELES I WANT.
TO ASSOCIATE MYSELF WITH THE
BEAUTIFUL COMMENTS IN
REFLECTIONS OF OUR COLLEAGUE
FROM SANTA MONICA.
AND AS WAS MENTIONED BY HIM AND
BY SO MANY OTHERS AT HER VERY
MOVING.
MEMORIAL SERVICE.
BARBIE ARE SLOTS HIS LIFE WAS
BUILT AROUND SERVICE TO OTHERS
GOVERNMENT SERVICE COMMUNITY
SERVICE PHILANTHROPIC WORK IN
THE INCREDIBLE LOVE AND DEVOTION
IN ENERGY.
THAT SHE DEVOTED TO HER FAMILY
TO HER FRIENDS AND REALLY TO THE
MOST VULNERABLE MEMBERS OF OUR
COMMUNITY.
IT'S I THINK IT'S APPROPRIATE
ALSO TO NOTE THAT JUST A FEW
DAYS AFTER BARBARA PASSED HER
SON DAVID WAS APPOINTED BY
GOVERNOR BROWN TO LOS ANGELES
SUPERIOR COURT.
AND I KNOW THAT SHE WOULD BEEN
HAVE BEEN INCREDIBLY PROUD OF
THAT ACCOMPLISHMENT.
BUT PARTICULARLY PROUD TO SEE
THAT HER FAMILY WAS CONTINUING
TO CARRY ON HER REAL LEGACY OF
SERVICE AND COMMITMENT TO
COMMUNITY AND HELPING THOSE IN
NEED AND SO.
BARBER YAROSLAVSKY WILL BE
DEEPLY MAST BUT I KNOW AS OUR
COLLEAGUE FROM SANTA MONICA
REFLECTED HER MEMORY REALLY WILL
BE A BLESSING TO TO HER FAMILY
ANTAR LARGER COMMUNITY AND I
RESPECTFULLY REQUEST THAT WE
ADJOURN IN HER MEMORY
[inaudible]
THANKS GABRIEL.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FLORA YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR GERMANY MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER TODAY I
ALSO INJURE IN THE MEMORY OF
CALDERON ELSE SEEING FOR THE
NEWMAN POLICE DEPARTMENT.
RECENTLY LOST HIS LIFE IN THE
LINE OF DUTY.
CORPORAL THING WAS JUST THIRTY
THREE YEARS OLD WHEN HE WAS SHOT
AND KILLED.
A ROUTINE TRAFFIC STOP EARLY
MORNINGS OF DECEMBER.
TWENTY SIX TWO THOUSAND EIGHT
THE SUSPECT TO SHOCK OR POSTING
WAS ARRESTED TWO DAYS LATER AND
CHARGED WITH MURDER OF A POLICE
OFFICER.
CORPORAL SING IMMIGRATED FROM
THE ISLAND NATION OF FIJI.
AND AGAIN THE STUDY CRIMINAL
JUSTICE BUT AT TO JUNIOR COLLEGE
IN.
TWO THOUSAND FIVE BEGIN YOUR
LONG FORCES A CADET.
BUTTER LIKE POLICE DEPARTMENT.
WENT ON TO JOIN THE NEW POLICE
DEPARTMENT IN.
TWO THOUSAND ELEVEN SEVERAL
THING WAS CONSTITUENT OF THE
TWELFTH DISTRICT.
RESIDED IN MODESTO WITH THIS LET
ME LIVE MICAH AND THEIR INFANT
SON.
SEVERAL THINGS SURVIVED BY HIS
WIFE IN THIS COUPLE THINGS
SURVIVING WIFE.
AND THEIR SON RECEIVED AN
OUTPOURING OF EMOTIONAL.
FINANCIAL SUPPORT GOING TO THEIR
SON'S COLLEGE EDUCATION FOR THE
VERY NEAR FUTURE.
OUR THOUGHTS PRAYERS AND LOVE
ARE WITH THIS FOR OUR OF LARGER
LAW ENFORCEMENT FAMILY IN THE
COMMUNITY OF NEWMAN AND THE
POLICE DEPARTMENT.
SO COLLEAGUES AS WE GO FORWARD --
MOVING ON I JUST PRAY THAT WE
CAN ALL COME TOGETHER AS A BODY.
AND PROTECT THOSE IT TOOK AN
OATH TO PROTECT US AS WELL AS
PROTECTING OUR COMMUNITY THERE
IS A FIX.
THAT WE ALL HAVE A PART IN
MAKING AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
MAKE IT WITH EACH AND EVERYONE
OF YOU THANK YOU.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GRAY OR ALSO
RECOGNIZE ON THIS A GERMAN
[inaudible]
THANK.
HEY MISTER SPEAKER MEMBERS.
I JOIN MY COLLEAGUE. FOR RIVEN
IN.
HONORING CORPORAL SAYING --
COVER SAY WAS A CONSTITUENT OF
MY COLLEAGUE WHICH FOR WORKED IN
MY DISTRICT.
PATROLLED THE STREETS OF NEW IN
A SMALL COMMUNITY ON THE WEST
SIDE OF MERCED COUNTY AND IN OUR
EVERYDAY.
MAN A WOMEN LIKE KARPAL SINGH
PUT THEIR LIVES ON THE LINE. TO
KEEP US SAFE AND KEEP OUR
COMMUNITY SAFE.
IT'S A TREMENDOUS LOSS.
HAVING ATTENDED --
THE SERVICES LAST WEEK YOU COULD
SEE THE JOY THE LOVE.
WILL HAD FOR CORPORAL SAYING --
IT'S A INCREDIBLE INCREDIBLE.
DIFFICULT LOSS IN SUCH A SMALL
DEPARTMENT.
SUCH A SMALL TIGHT KNIT
COMMUNITY --
THE ENTIRE 20% WE DISTRICT
MYSELF INCLUDED IS IN MOURNING --
WE KEEP HIS.
FAMILY AND FRIENDS.
IN OUR THOUGHTS AND PRAYERS I
WOULD ASK THE ENTIRE.
ASSEMBLY TO JOIN ME --
IN HONORING CORPORAL SAYING
RETURNING IS MEMBER THANK YOU.
THANK YOU SOMEWHERE RIGHT.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER BLOOM BACK TO
FOR AN ADDITIONAL A GERMAN.
MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER AND
MISTER SPEAKER I'VE BE WILLING
TO BET THAT YOU AND SOON YOU'RE
BEAUTIFUL TO CHILDREN.
AND EVERYONE OF US.
ON THE FLOOR OF THIS HELLO
CHAMBER HAVE A FAVORITE
SUPERHERO.
A FOR ME IT'S SPIDER MAN --
AND FOR EACH OF YOU.
ARE AT IT MAYBE SOMEONE
DIFFERENT --
BUT IT IS THE A SAD THEN THAT I
MUST RISE TO ADJOURN IN THE
MEMORY OF STANDLEY.
OF WHO WAS BORN STANLEY MARTIN
LIEBER COMIC BOOK WRITER EDITOR.
AND TRUE LEGEND.
IF YOU'VE.
EVER READ OR SEEN A CAR ONE OF
THE COMIC BOOK SAID THAT HE WAS
A INTEGRAL IN CREATING OR THE
MOVIES BASED ON THOSE CHARACTERS
SPIDER MAN X. MEN.
IRON MAN MORE RECENTLY THE BLACK
PANTHER AND DOZENS OF OTHERS IN
BETWEEN.
IF YOU'RE FAMILIAR WITH ANY OF
THEM THEN YOU WITNESSED THE
PRODUCT OF LEASE WORK AND HIS
LASTING LEGACY ON POP CULTURE.
HE WAS BORN IN DECEMBER OF
NINETEEN TWENTY TWO ROMANIAN
JEWISH IMMIGRANTS.
BORN IN MANHATTAN HE WOULD LATER
SETTLE IN THE BRONX WITH HIS
FAMILY WERE A GRADUATED FROM
HIGH SCHOOL.
FROM A YOUNG AGE.
HE WANTED TO BECOME A WRITER
ALTHOUGH HE INITIALLY DRAFT OF
WRITING SERIOUS LITERATURE --
ALTHOUGH THOSE ARE --
THERE ARE THOSE OF US WHO WOULD
ARGUE THAT COMIC BOOKS ARE
SERIOUS LITERATURE BUT HE
DREAMED OF WRITING --
OF TRADITIONAL LITERATURE.
NOT COMIC BOOKS.
HIS BREAK INTO THE COMIC BOOK
WORLD CAME SOON AFTER HE
GRADUATED HIGH SCHOOL WHEN HE
BECAME AN ASSISTANT OUT.
OF A COMPANY NAMED TIMELY COMICS
WHICH WOULD LATER BECOME THE
MORE FAMILIAR MARVEL COMICS. TWO
YEARS AFTER JOINING HE WROTE HIS
FIRST COMIC BOOK CAPTAIN AMERICA
FOILS THE TRAITOR'S REVENGE.
UNDER THE PSEUDONYM OF STANLEY
WHICH HE WOULD LATER ADOPT AS
HIS LEGAL NAME.
LEAN LISTED IN THE ARMY IN
NINETEEN FORTY TWO SERVING IN
THE SIGNAL CORPS WORRY WROTE
MANUALS TRAINING FILMS AND
SLOGANS.
HE RETURNED TO TIMELY COMICS AS
EDITOR AFTER HIS MILITARY
SERVICE AND IN NINETEEN SIXTY
ONE LOST MARBLES FIRST NEW
SUPERHERO TEAM.
THE FANTASTIC.
FOUR TOGETHER WITH ARTIST JACK
KIRBY AND STEVE DITKO LEE
CREATED CHARACTERS SUCH AS THE
HULK IRON MAN THE X. MEN AND
SPIDER MAN.
UNLIKE PREVIOUS COMIC BOOK
HEROES HIS CHARACTERS WERE
COMPLEX THEY WERE FLAWED.
THEY WERE.
HEROES WHO. TO US.
THE STORIES IN LEE'S COMICS
ADDRESS REAL LIFE ISSUES ALSO
FROM POLITICAL ELECTIONS TO
STUDENT ACTIVISM.
ANY HELP BREAK BARRIERS BY
CREATING MAINSTREAM COMICS FIRST
BLACK SUPERHERO THE BLACK
PANTHER.
TODAY LEASE COMICS ARE AT THE
HEART OF A MULTI BILLION DOLLAR
INTERNATIONAL PHENOMENON.
HE REMAINED INVOLVED WITH MANY
OF THE RECENT FILM ADAPTATIONS
SERVING AS AN EXECUTIVE PRODUCER
AND FREQUENTLY MAKING CAMEOS IN
THE FILM STE.
LEE INSPIRED ENTIRE GENERATIONS
AND CONTINUES TO DO SO TODAY.
HIS SIGNATURE CATCH PHRASE WAS
EXCELSIOR WHICH IS THE LATIN
TERM MEANT TO IMPART THE NOTION
OF MOVING EVER ONWARD TO GREATER
THINGS.
HE PASSED AWAY ON NOVEMBER
TWELFTH.
NEAR HIS HOME IN BEVERLY HILLS
AT THE AGE OF NINETY FIVE AFTER
BATTLING PNEUMONIA AND IS
SURVIVED BY HIS DAUGHTER JC.
AND YOUNGER BROTHER LARRY.
PLEASE JOIN ME IN SAYING FEAR.
AS WE ADJOURN IN THE MEMORY OF
THE LEGENDARY STANLEY.
THANK YOU MISTER BLOW.
ASSEMBLYMEMBER ROMMEL'S YOU ARE
RECOGNIZED FOR YOUR GERMAN
MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER SPEAKER.
TODAY I RISE TO REQUESTED JR
MEMORY OF ROBERT DAVID MANZANO.
ROBERT WAS A RESIDENT OF
HIGHLAND AND WAS BOTH A
CONSTITUENT AN ACTIVE MEMBER OF
OUR COMMUNITY OFTEN VOLUNTEERING
HIS TIME AND ENERGY FOR THE
COMMUNITY EVENTS ON THE SALMON
WELL INDIAN RESERVATION.
HE PASS OF THE AGE OF SEVENTY
FOUR YEARS OLD ON DECEMBER
SIXTEENTH OF LAST YEAR.
ROBERT WAS BORN IN SAN MARINO
CALIFORNIA ON SEPTEMBER FIFTH.
NINETEEN FORTY FOUR HE MARRIED
NORMA JEANE MANZANO HIS PARTNER
FOR LIFE.
HE WAS AN ACTIVE MEMBER OF OUR
COMMUNITY ON THE SEMI WINDING
RESERVATION ALWAYS READY TO TAKE
THE KIDS TO DIFFERENT PLACES
THAT ARE THERE AND SUPPORTING
ARE YOU.
ROBERT WAS ALWAYS READY AND
WILLING TO OFFER A HELPING HAND
TO COMMUNITY EVENTS REACHING OUT
TO CONTRIBUTE WHEREVER HE COULD.
IT IS WITHOUT A DOUBT THE
ROBBERS TIRELESS CONTRIBUTIONS
TO THE RESERVATION COMMUNITY
MADE THE SEVEN WELL PEOPLE MUCH
STRONGER.
ROBERT LIVES ON THROUGH HIS SON
DAVID AND HIS TWO DAUGHTERS
DELORES AND DIANA.
AND A SEVEN GRAND CHILDREN.
HIS PASSION FOR LIFE AND IS
ACTIVE PRESENCE IN OUR COMMUNITY
WILL BE DEARLY MISSED.
I RESPECTFULLY REQUEST ADJOURNED
IN HIS MEMORY.
THANK YOU MISTER ROMMEL'S.
MEMBERS PLEASE BRING THE NAMES
THE DESK TO BE PRINTED IN THE
JOURNAL REQUEST TO JOURNEY
MEMORY WILL BE DEEMED READ IT
PRINTED IN THE JOURNAL.
ALL OTHER ITEMS REMAINING WE
PASS RETAINALL MOTION SHALL BE
CONTINUED.
SEEING AND HEARING NO FOR THE
BUSINESS I'M READY TO ENTERTAIN
A MOTION TO ADJOURN.
MISTER CALDERON MOVES MISTER
FLORA SECONDS.
AT THIS HOUSE STANDS ADJOURNED
UNTIL MONDAY JANUARY FOURTEENTH.
AT ONE PM IN A QUORUM CALL IS
LIFTED